[Musique]
bon
t'en veux qu'on mette way film mary j
j'aime bien les chevaux
neuf semaines et demie tu connais je les
ai pas vues mais ouais je connais ouais
c'est génial c'est super et des trois
premiers rangs cas ça m'a dit c'est le
film avec la fameuse scène de strip
tease là c'est ça ouais c'est sa
thérapie tu nous foulons mon cas avec
tes prises à l'eau sarah plus personne
n'utilise deux prises péritel plus
personne tout le monde utilise d'être
fixe salah pénalties énervé à toi juste
pas être la bonne entrée ben voilà c'est
sûr avaient un crédit
oui ces coûts mais non c'est pas comme
si cycle est remonté comme c'est mignon
moi j'aime bien ce film parce que tu
vois c'est pas seulement acheter
[Musique]
le malaise
je suis sûr que sa bande sec à les
regarde sahara juste un petit coup
d'oeil trop merde en vie alors
sa bande
on peut mettre autre chose tu as j'adore
le revoir ce film qu'elle adore leur
saison film de branlettes et vas-y que
je peux tout la chatte sur mickey rourke
halal a piqué c'est vachement bien
citons films préférés moi j'aime bien et
si je reprenais la clope je vais faire
la liste des points positifs et négatifs
alors bas jeux tous plus j'ai une très
belle peau j'ai retrouvé le goût ou quoi
ça va on connaît par coeur ce film ne va
pas lui un peu l'amour comme les malades
j'ai mon coeur qui bat normalement
saraiva pas normalement là mon coeur il
va trop vite
adnan ahmad connemara connemara
[Musique]
c'est super discret ça comme approche a
touché un truc c'est gênant et ringard
on en plus regardent
il est hyper mal à l'aise au pauvre
garçon là je te met mal à l'aise mais
non non pas du tout mais alors bien ça
qui m'a pas le dire un peu mal à l'aise
enfin ça c'est plutôt cela comme un coup
moi avec sa crête était vraiment qu'une
salle punk t'encule et ta mère la [ __ ]
et pas nickel non médical et ben tu veux
savoir ce que tu as tu choisi santé la
pire des cônes à fond d'un cul les deux
pistes que la terre et chaque est
superbe et bats-toi cette fois d'être
[Musique]
écoutés y aller je suis désolé je un bon
déjà oui j'ai des trucs à faire et puis
je crois pas que c'était le bon moment
et que c'est pas grave en concert non
mais si je suis je suis vraiment désolé
je nous vois bientôt
est ce que tu penses que la prochaine
fois qu'on le voit on pourrait se voir
tous les deux enfin le dire sans ta
soeur carrément cool
yes
[Musique]
ah parce que là on va regarder jusqu'à
la fin en fait pour ta bonne et si tu
veux tu peux cliquer sur la prise
péritel
non mais ça rate et sérieuse note une
flotte avec des prises péritel péritel
péritel non cliquez plutôt sur la
jaquette du dvd comme ça vous pourrez
voir le making of ou enfin c'est
important quand même que les gens
s'abonnent comme ça ils pourront voir
les autres vidéos péritel non mais la
honte quelle fougue entérite n